[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe heute eine tolle
muttertags idee für euch ich habe hier
kleine törtchen gebacken mit diesen b
seerosen die törtchen
ich finde es ist so ein rezept das sieht
kompliziert aus unserer noch sterne
küche und so richtig speziell und ganz
fein aber es ist wirklich ein super
einfaches rezept ihr braucht dafür nur
ein ofen blech denn ich mag erst mal
einen blechkuchen und wetter und später
die törtchen einfach ausstechen und
stapeln wirklich super einfach das
einzige was ihr bedenken müsste seerosen
die trockenen etwa zwei stunden im
backofen
das ist das einzige ansonsten geht es
wirklich super schnell
ich mache jetzt zuerst einmal den teig
für den rührteig verwende ich sieben
eiweiß eine prise salz 120 gramm zucker
170 gramm weiche butter noch mal 120
gramm zucker vanille extrakt 7 eigelbe
150 gramm mehl 100 gramm mandeln und
pistazien gemischt und entweder einen
esslöffel milch oder amaretto schnee mit
zuerst das eiweiß es kommt hier in eine
rührschüssel und ich hab das jetzt
getrennt damit einfach noch luftiger
wird und so kann ich auch auf backpulver
verzichten
eine prise salz dazu das eiweiß so lässt
sich schneller steif schlagen jetzt erst
mal kurz streit schlage
jetzt hier langsam den zucker einrieseln
lassen und das mache ich jetzt damit das
eiweiß gleich darunter eben nicht flockt
einfach den zucker kurz einrühren dann
ein kleiner schüssel wechsel und hier
jetzt den flacherer nehmen jetzt kann
ich hier die weiche butter reingeben in
die rührschüssel den restlichen zucker
und mehl extrakt und dann die butter
zucker masse für etwa zwei bis drei
minuten verrühren bis sie schön cremig
ist
jetzt gebe ich dir ein ein alter nach
dem anderen
so verbindet sich so richtig schön mit
der butter masse
[Musik]
und in der zwischenzeit gern schon mal
die pistazien mandeln fein mahlen
[Musik]
ja ich jetzt die wundervolle butter
zucker eigelb mischung eiweiß hier habe
ich die pistazien und mandeln
ich habs jetzt halb halb gemacht hat
sagt immer pistazien sind zu teuer
benutzt nicht zu viele
und jetzt werde ich alles im wechsel
unterheben gemeinsam mit dem mehl und
milch und statt der milch könnt ihr wie
gesagt auch amaretto nehmen da könnt ihr
so ein bisschen geschmack mit rein geben
oder ihn nehmen zum beispiel auch
pistazien liga das wird auch perfekt
passen
das habe ich alles unterhalten und
medizin wacklig mit dem bug rahmen und
ich möchte jetzt einen effekt machen das
heißt die törtchen werden verschiedene
farbig sein
angefangen von hell bis zu grün
also werde ich jetzt erstmal ein drittel
dieser masse hier vorne eingießen noch
nicht verstreichen
die übrige masse wird jetzt halbiert
dann nehme ich mir jetzt ein bisschen
von der track masse heraus und färbt sie
mit lebensmittelfarbe passte grün ein
das mache ich jetzt so weil sich die
farbe dann einfach besser verteilt
[Musik]
ich glaube dieses kc grün wäre als
erstes konkretes helle pistaziengrün
gefällt mir jetzt gut das heißt das wird
jetzt die hälfte farbe und dessen
verbindung setzen so machen wir das
jetzt kurz umstrukturiert
[Musik]
da ist jetzt nur wichtig nicht zu lange
zu rühren
ansonsten könnte einfach auch gerne
einen halben teelöffel backpulver
zufügen damit nicht die ganze luft raus
geschlagen wird
ganz vorsichtig verstreichen aber du in
die eine richtung die farben nicht
miteinander vermischen davon nicht
abziehen
falls nötig einfach mit der teig karte
einmal drüber gehen damit schön glatt
wird
jetzt im ofen backen und dann abkühlen
lassen und in der zeit werde ich schon
mal db seerosen spritzen
für die b seerosen verwende ich drei
eiweiß eine prise salz 150 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel stärke und rosa
lebensmittel verpasste zuerst schlage
ich weiß hier steif mit einer prise salz
und übrigen eigelbe die könnte verwenden
um zum beispiel level körper zu machen
oder einen vanillepudding also eigelb
finde ich wenn man das übrig hat da gibt
es ganz viele tolle rezepte auf einem
kanal
da könnte und dann gerne eine
resteverwertung machen
[Musik]
jetzt den zucker langsam dazu rieseln
lassen und dann soll es fünf minuten
weiter schlagen damit sich der zucker
schön löst ihr könnt auch diesen finger
test machen also finger rein wenn die
maschine aus ist natürlich und zwischen
den fingern das eiweiß dann reiben und
dann merkt man auch schon auf der zunge
gelöst ist oder nicht
gebe ich jetzt noch die stärke kurz
unter die bbc sieht immer schön aus
schmeckt lecker und jetzt gebe ich hier
ein paar tropfen rosa verpasste
rheinfahrt passte nehme ich immer ganz
gerne weil sie nicht flüssig hier das
heißt sie verändert die konsistenz des
teiges nicht oder der masse nicht
jetzt nehme ich die helle masse und
füllten einen spritzbeutel bisher an den
rand ich mache nämlich ein marmor effekt
und wertet die masse in drei etappen
färben also hellrosa und wir an den rand
dann etwas dunkleres rosa und an den
rand mache ich dann noch mal ein
bisschen dunkler
schön verschließt und jetzt wird jeder
hose individuell hier vorne habe ich
jetzt ne spritztour und zwar eine
zulassungsstelle und dir zeit habe ich
mir verkürzt ich habe hier ein
backpapier genommen und auf die
rückseite schon mal kreise aufgezeichnet
ich nehme später zum ausschließen der
törtchen diesen ausstecher und habe
jetzt aber einen kleineren gewählt für
die b seerosen denn die gehen immer im
ofen noch mal ein bisschen auf
einfach schön auf die rückseite des
papiers zeichnen und dann den
spritzbeutel senkrecht halten in der
mitte beginnen und nach außen spritzen
[Musik]
die werden jetzt schön im ofen bei heiß
luftgetrocknet wenn ihr keine heißluft
habt oder umluft habt können die auch
ober unterhitze nehmen aber ich möchte
nicht dass die seerosen gebacken werden
die sollen wirklich schön trocknen die
farbe behalten und ihr könnt ab und zu
gerne mal die offenen tür öffnen um
einfach die feuchtigkeit rauszulassen
der kuchen ist gebacken und bereits
abgekühlt den kann ich jetzt auslösen
und wenn er an der oberfläche ist so wie
ich hier leicht frauen geworden ist ist
es gar nicht schlimm
keine sorge denn unten ist er richtig
schön grün
das ist nur die oberste schicht vom
bakken
ich werde jetzt einfach abdecken
dann noch mal schön luftdicht abdecken
damit er nicht austrocknet und in den
kühlschrank stellen
denn diese törtchen die mache ich jetzt
morgen weiter hier sind übrigens die b
seerosen die sind echt super aus und ihr
könnt dann feststellen dass sie trocken
sind wenn ihr sie belegt und wenn sie
vom backblech vom backpapier gut runter
gehen ich stelle jetzt doch noch mal
kurz in den backofen
und wenn sie dann auch komplett
durchgetrocknet sind kann ich morgen die
törtchen fertig stellen
die wie seerosen sind jetzt schon
getrocknet die stelle ich jetzt noch
fertig ihr könnt sie im prinzip auch
schon so lassen aber ich finde so noch
besondere ich habe jetzt hier 100 gramm
weiße schokolade bereits gehackt und
stellen sie auf mein wasserbad 50 gramm
habe ich hier noch übrig ich mache jetzt
einfach die temperatur also zwei drittel
der schokolade schmelzen herunternehmen
vom wasserbad das restliche drittel dazu
und dann hat die kuvertüre die perfekte
weiter verarbeitungs temperatur behält
natürlich ihre form beim abkühlen als
auch bei raumtemperatur die schmilzt
nicht und sie bekommen keinen grauen
schleier
das habe ich hier zwei kollegen meinen
torten retter drauf so wird nämlich
datenretter schön kalt und die
schokolade wird gleich fest wir seerosen
die lager ich immer bei raumtemperatur
und ich sehe jetzt auch alle super schön
trocken wenn sie einen kühlschrank
kommen werden wir nämlich feucht das
heißt das wollen wir nicht
ich hab ich jetzt noch pistazien gemalt
und einige so ein bisschen grob gelassen
richtig schön das dachte buch hat mich
sehen
und jetzt mache ich so ich nehme eine
vision tauchen sie mit der unterseite in
die kuvertüre ein bisschen darf an den
rand und dann in die pistazien und die
kuvertüre wird jetzt richtig schön und
schnell fest wenn es eben jetzt hier auf
den torten retter legt
der kuchen ist es schön kalt jetzt kann
ich ihn raus stürzen
ich nehme es einfach noch mal eine back
folie darauf einen torten retter jetzt
sehen wir gleich ob es geklappt hat mit
der farbe
jetzt nehme ich einfach einen ausstecher
und jetzt könnt ihr auch wirklich schön
ausprobieren ob das passt passt perfekt
und steche jetzt hier schöne kreise aus
und setzte sie dann später farblich
versetzt zusammen
die stelle ich kurz zur seite und kann
jetzt schon mal die torten creme zu
bereiten
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach erdbeer
sonderfahrt habt ihr wirklich richtig
schön in erdberg geschmack und die könnt
ihr entweder zubereiten mit 800 gramm
sahne chemisch zum beispiel quark und
sahne das mache ich jetzt so also 400
gramm magerquark und 400 gramm sahne
dazu und dann mit dem seiner fahrt steif
schlagen und so habt ihr wirklich super
schnell eine leckere etwa creme und werk
ein apple fan ist kann zum beispiel auch
schoko seiner partner nehmen
da hat den leckeres schokotörtchen oder
sind und rezepte drin die ihr einfach
verwenden könnt mit veganen zutaten
und ich habe jetzt hier quark und quark
ist eine relativ weiche masse wie zum
beispiel mascarpone oder frischkäse
nimmt dann braucht ihr auch nicht die
ganze tüte also da könnt ihr wirklich
langsam herantasten drei viertel reicht
oft oder auch mal die hälfte
das schaut ihr einfach wie ihr euch die
festigkeit der creme gefällt und vor
allem ob ihr denn von rettberg geschmack
wollt wo damit geschwächt
und die creme mir jetzt einfach in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt auch mit einer
großen stern thüle und dann können wir
die törtchen schon befüllen
ich setze jetzt erstmal immer drei tiger
aufeinander ich schaue ob ich drei oder
zwei mache aber ich glaube schon dass es
drei werden und die dunkelsten sind bei
mir unten kommt jetzt die creme rein
dann der nächste tortenboden und so
werden die törtchen zusammengesetzt
und kurz vor dem verzehr lege ich hier
dann noch die rose drauf ich glaube das
ist echt zum dessert ich meine herbst
gesehen ist gar nicht so schwierig aber
der wow effekt ist da ihr müsst einfach
einmal eine bizkit platte packen oder
backen backen backen und die creme zu
bereiten die b seerosen und dann sei da
echt schon fertig also super könnt ihr
wunderbar vorbereiten
ja das gefällt mir sehr gut lg display
und wie gesagt die seerosen nicht den
kühlschrank sondern bei raumtemperatur
lagern aber die törtchen
wir müssen natürlich in den kühlschrank
und aus den resten mache ich noch kleine
pralinen
das heißt ich nehme jetzt hier den teig
wenn ihr übrigens mehr von den törtchen
machen möchte die creme reicht auf jeden
fall für zwei bleche kuchen aus also
könnt ihr auch gerne die doppelte
portion zubereiten oder einfach die
hälfte der creme jetzt zerbröseln mit
der creme vermischen die pistazien habe
ich auch noch übrig und dann will sich
die kugel in glitzer schminken
die weiße schokolade jetzt auch noch da
wird auch schon fest und dann einfach
schön vermischen zu kleinen kugeln
formen und in spitzer schwänzen
wer möchte kann jetzt hier natürlich
noch ein bisschen glitzer schon drüber
streuen aber ich muss sagen ich finde
sie so schon richtig gut glitzer finde
ich zwar immer gut aber ich hier mag ich
diese matte optik sehr gerne probieren
tue ich es nicht denn ich möchte gleich
noch mitnehmen zu meiner mama und das
rezept könnt ihr nachlesen auch cds -
blockte eben wie gesagt dass es von mir
nur ein vorschlag des staats hier mit
erdbeere
ihr könnt auch andere geschmäcker nehmen
und natürlich auch andere farben das
rezept gibt es auch sallys - blog.de und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß für
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal
ich bitte bringt jetzt so essen erst die
seerose und dann das
[Musik]